la crise russo occidental toujours la
une de l'actualité ici depuis plusieurs
jours washington affirme que la russie
envisagerait de filmer une fausse
attaque ukrainienne un prétexte de créer
de toutes pièces pour envahir son voisin
selon les états unis pourtant appelé par
un journaliste à apporter des preuves de
ces allégations le porte-parole de la
diplomatie américaine a botté en touche
elle est précision avec notre
correspondant à washington tom abonnés
c'est une scène relativement surprenante
et inhabituelle aux états unis ce jeudi
le porte-parole de la diplomatie
américaine
ned price exposait face à la presse d
allégations sur une supposée attaque
sous faux drapeau que pour ré fomenté la
russie selon washington moscou pourrait
se servir de vidéos mises en scène pour
justifier une attaque contre l'ukraine
des accusations qui ont trouvé écho dans
la plupart des médias américains mais
lors de la conférence de presse
organisée donc ce jeudi l'expérimenté
journalistes de lagence associative
press matt lee a demandé au porte parole
de la diplomatie américaine d'étayer ses
accusations
ce qui a donné lieu à un vif échange
voici un extrait
ce que je vous dis c'est que ce sont des
informations qui sont à notre
disposition nous les mettons à votre
disposition pour deux raisons la
première est d'essayer de dissuader les
russes de poursuivre cette activité
deuxièmement au cas où nous ne serions
pas en mesure de le faire au cas où les
russes irait de l'avant pour que ce soit
clair comme le jour pour mettre à lui le
fait que ça l'a toujours été une
tentative de la part de la fédération de
russie de fabriquer un prétexte qu'elle
plus taxes
oui mais vous n'avez aucune preuve pour
l'étayer à part ce que vous dites c'est
comme si vous disiez nous pensons nous
avons des informations selon lesquelles
les russes pourraient faire ceci mais
vous ne nous dit pas quels sont ces
informations
nous essayons de dissuader les russes
d'aller de l'avant avec ce titre
activités c'est pourquoi nous rendons
public aujourd'hui si les russes ne vont
pas de l'avant avec cela cela ne
signifie pas etc sauf acto qui n'ont
jamais eu l'intention de le faire
mais alors c'est indémontrable je veux
dire mon dieu quelles sont les preuves
que vous avez qui suggère que les russes
planifie même cela m'a debout je veux
dire je ne dis pas qu'ils ne le font pas
mais vous venez juste de dire cela et
vous attendez à ce que nous croyons sans
montrer l'ombre d'une preuve que c'est
réellement vrai à part que lorsque je
demande ou quelqu'un d'autre demande
quelles sont les informations vous dit
eh bien je viens de vous les donner ce
qui est juste une déclaration de votre
part
vous avez dit vous même que vous êtes
dans ce domaine depuis longtemps vous
savez que lorsque nous rendons publique
d information des informations de
renseignement
nous le faisons de manière à protéger
les sources et les méthodes sensible
vous savez également que nous faisons
nous déclassifier les informations
uniquement lorsque nous avons confiance
dans ces informations si vous doutez si
les douter de la crédibilité du
gouvernement américain du gouvernement
britannique d'autres gouvernements et
que vous voulez trouver du réconfort
dans les informations que les russes
diffuse un réconfort c'est à vous de le
faire rire
un échange pour le moins animée qui
continue de faire réagir aux états unis
certains rappelant tous les mensonges
déjà exprimé dans le passé par les
autorités américaines que ce soit sur la
syrie sur l'afghanistan où bien
évidemment sur l'irak edouard snowdon
ainsi résumé la situation dans un tweet
relativement cynique quiconque
questionne un communiqué dit il délivré
sur une estrade et soit une marionnette
des russes de l'état islamique ou des
deux à désolé vous connaissez les règles
fin de citation cette séquence
intervient peu de temps après une autre
remise en question de la version
américaine des événements en ukraine les
autorités américaines avaient évoqué à
plusieurs reprises qu'une attaque russe
était je cite imminente mais la maison
blanche fait marche arrière désormais la
porte parole de la maison blanche a
annoncé cette semaine qu'elle
n'emploierait plus ce terme d'imminent
écoutez je les employés une fois je
pense que d'autres ont également
employer ce terme et ensuite nous avons
cessé de l'utiliser car je pense que
cela envoie un message que nous n'avions
pas l'intention d'envoyer qui était que
nous saurions que le président poutine a
pris une décision voilà donc deux
exemples récents qui atteste d'un
certaine l'embarras quand la version
officielle de la diplomatie américaine
est remise en question y compris par des
journalistes américains ce qu'on peut
toutefois constater c'est que dans une
grande majorité des cas la rhétorique
gouvernementale se retrouve quasiment
tel quel dans les colonnes des
principaux médias aux états unis